if you control the money you control the  world and so when you have something  like a central bank digital currency you  can just program it in order to promote  different political or woke ideologies  whatever it is so the world economic  forum for example we're talking about  implementing a carbon allowance which  basically means each individual will be  given a certain amount of carbon they  are allowed to emit how do they do this  well you program the money so say for  example you bought a lot of meat one  week you could actually reach short  carbon allowance and so when you go to  fill up your car go see family or  whatever it is your money could get  declined and so now what they've done is  those unelected Elites are the world  economic Forum have implemented their  political ideology through a central  bank digital currency it's the most  effective way to implement these  tyrannical woke ideologies